ronaldinho qui va se marier non pas avec
une femme mais avec deux femmes deux
femmes
ah oui alors les deux femmes en question
sont prescillia coelho et mais a très
souvent absolument haricots des la
prière depuis 2012 et visiblement il
était pas rassasié il ôte il a rencontré
en 2016 et les l'os devrait être
célébrée dans la ville de santa monica
pourquoi santa monica au brésil c'est
bien parce que là c'est permis et oui là
c'est permis alors la beauce connaissez
pas religieux bah vous outre bien à huy
alors est-ce que alors on va pas
demander tout de suite si ça vous choque
mais c'est juste vous pourriez envisager
par jean-michel au hasard jeudi enfin
que deux je suis pas une bonne compagnie
franchement je préfère lambert dès
qu'une grand mère des deux os
quel s'amuserait ensemble sans toi aussi
c'est un choix religieux à la limite ok
mais là c'est même pas le cas ça veut
dire c'est une honte c'est juste que le
gars il n'arrive pas à se décider et
choisit l'une choisi l'autre alors je me
marie avec les deux écoutera besson pour
écouter sont les landais faut arrêter je
veux dire c'est ses messages tout les 3
vallées
il n'a pas mené une bague de mariage pas
les mêmes non médical mais c'est normal
doit se désengager
quand ça vous aurait simplifié la vie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
depardon faisait le buzz marianne
reynaud fond de 6,2 torse et de pension
alimentaire
merci merci et fanny et bien fondée par
les noms des sciences et non vous êtes
seul
oui tant que pour vous c'est des choses
car il est très joli mais ça c'est
gentil d'ailleurs alors je sais pas si
si ça enfin c'est un lien mais votre
colis est quand même j'aimerais qu'on
fasse un gros plan sur votre colis parce
que mes amis et moi j'ai vu ça dans les
limbes non plus à marquer quand même
cattin sur votre style
alors cet institut car c'est un métier
non non pas du tout j'ai pas dit que
j'étais vous je suis possible et bien je
suis pas au ballon je suppose qu'il n'y
ait pas de monde en même temps un délire
avec des amis c'est tout ah ouais bon
ami de jean-michel et pourquoi quatre
d'entre vous savent rien c'est dans
notre groupe d'amis en fait on s'appelle
les quêtes mais ça en délire amical away
alors on pouvait voir venir sur
ronaldinho qui devrait épouser de femmes
il parait il lui l'a dit d'ailleurs il a
démenti ce n'est pas vrai il n'a pas
épousé deux femmes
on a la vidéo regarde le monde
message nous donne et alors est ce que
c'est un démenti pour qu'on lui foute la
paix est ce que vous y croyez ce que
c'est une figure de style
gilles ya pas de fumée sans feu et en
plus très franchement vous disiez tout à
l'heure mais elles acceptent elles sont
d'accord mais gilles contraire benjamin
heureusement qu'elles sont d'accord oui
bien sûr non mais c'est une honte de
toute façon c'est une honte parce que
ronaldinho c'était déjà une ruine à la
fin de sa carrière
mais trois ans bien au foot il a été
ballon d'or après c'était fini et c'est
une honte depuis la fin de sa carrière
il multiplie les phrases qui fait
n'importe quoi franchement c'est
scandaleux
il faut dénoncer ce type